If you do a Syrex array test for food allergies, are there results forever?
Or can your food allergies change?
So I think I answered that, but I answered again. No, they're not forever. Your food allergies
can change. So when you do a Syrex can, let's say, some can change for the better. Meaning they will
go back to normal rage and then you'll have, and that would be all great. But that's not just
always the case. Because when you change your diet, you, okay, you eat less of what was positive
on that test. Well, you have to eat more of something else. And the truth is, is not even if you
don't eat more of something else, it's because you have a damaged gut. That's why you have the antibodies
in the first place. So it's going to take time to heal that damaged gut. So I do not ever
recommend running a Syrex 10, you know, more than like every six months. Because you've got to work
on healing your gut. So when you have a really bad test on that, it's not like, oh, you're just
sensitive to all these foods you can't eat anything for the rest of your life. No, no, no, it's just
telling you that your gut is so damaged. You got to heal your gut. So I've had people that
had irritable bowel syndrome or Crohn's disease and they test it. I mean, like everything was, it was,
it wasn't like what you're sensitive to. It's like, let's count the number of foods that you can't
eat. So then they would try to eat those foods. But if you're not healing the gut and call me that
and call me the immune response style, you're never going to get this positive better. So remember,
if you already have self-antibiotics, like in the case of Crohn's disease, they have antibodies to
GI tissue. So they have an autoimmune attack on their epithelial cells. It's many different
antibodies to different GI tissues that have. And let's say it's the epithelial cells that lie
the gut. And every time you cause an inflammation in the gut, you're going to cause more destruction
of self-tissue. So you have to decrease that cause of inflammation. So it's essential that these
people do a Cyrix tend to know one of the things that I really need to cut out for a period of time
while I'm trying to heal the gut. When you're dealing with autoimmune disease, if anybody has
has studied my course on that, you'll find out you have to find the triggers. And many times
food is at least a trigger that you have to calm that down. So that will change over time.
The more you could heal the gut, the more that you can make permanent changes for the better. Now some
food antibodies and antibodies to certain peptides have been proven over the course of
20 years that these tests have been available. That stick around longer. And that one of those is
gluten. But you know, I've seen gluten antibodies go back to normal and I've seen people that have
swored up and down that they don't eat one speck of gluten and they look at all cross-reactants and
such. And they still have gluten antibodies five years after their initial test. But it seems like
other ones seem to dissipate quite quickly. So that's the good news.